اختتمت في مدينه جده السعوديه القمه
العربيه في نسختها الثانيه والثلاثين
وادلى الرؤساء والزعماء العرب بكلمات
تطرقوا فيها الى واقع العمل العربي
المشترك والقضايا الساخنه المطروحه عليه
وسجلت القمه مشاركه الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد لاول مره في اشغالها بعد تجميد موقع
دمشق منذ سنه 2011
[موسيقى]
نناقش ذلك في ثلاثه مسارات في اي سياق
يمكن لنا ان نضع قمه جدا العربيه وما هي
اهم القضايا المطروحه على جدول اعمالها
وايضا كيف تبدو خارطه المواقف من القضايا
المطروحه وما فرص التوصل الى مخرجات فعاله
بشانها خاصه تلك التي تمثل محل خلاف بين
الدول الاعضاء نناقش كذلك كيف سيقدم العمل
العربي المشترك نفسه للشعوب العربيه التي
كثيرا انتقدته وللمجتمع الدولي المنهمك في
ملفات اخرى تبدو على مسافه من المنطقه
العربيه مثل الحرب في اوكرانيا وتصاعد
التوتر الامريكي الصيني
[موسيقى]
قمه التوافقات والمصالحات هكذا وصفت اغلب
كلمات الوفود العربيه في قمه جده هكذا
وصفت القمه في اشاره الى مساد الاجواء من
رغبه في التطلع الى المستقبل بمنسوب اقل
من الخلافات
والصراعات في ظرف اقليمي ودوليا يشهد
تحديات بالغه الخطوره عاده السؤال بقوه عن
واقعي ومستقبل العمل العربي المشتركه
وفيما اكدت مداخلات الرؤساء والزعماء
العرب على دقه اللحظه العربيه والدوليه
مشددين على ضروره توحيد الكلمه ونبد
الخلافات وتكثيف الجهود لانهاء النزاعات
القائمه في المنطقه العربيه يبقى انعكاس
كل ذلك
رهينه ما يصدر عن القمه من قرارات وتوصيات
مجلس الجامعه العربيه على مستوى القمه
اعتمد في ختام اعمالها ما باتي يعرف
باعلان جده اعلان تضمن عددا من النقاط
لعلى من اهمها التاكيد على اهميه تكثيف
الجهود للتوصل لتسويه عادله للقضيه
الفلسطينيه الاعلان شدد على وقف التدخلات
الخارجيه في الشؤون الداخليه للدول
العربيه ودعا اعلان جده الى تكثيف الجهود
العربيه الراميه الى مساعده الدول العربيه
المعنيه على تجاوز ازمتها هذا ورحب اعلان
جده بالاتفاق الذي تم بين السعوديه وايران
لتفعيل اتفاقيه التعاون الامني والاقتصادي
بينهما
[موسيقى]
نرحب بالاستوديو دكتور سعد بن عمر بن عمر
مدير مركز القرن العربي للدراسات ومن
بيروت بالدكتور عبد الله الشايجي العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الكويت ابدا بك دكتور
سعد
ما اهم ما في هذه القمه وكيف يمكن ان
يترجم الى مستوى طموحات الشعوب العربيه
بدات لنا القمه العربيه اكثر توافقا وهو
المطلوب في هذه المرحله يعني لاحظنا ان كل
الوفود وبكلماتهم
وارائهم انهم يعني
يضعون التضامن العربي والنبذه الخلافات
امام عيونهم وهناك اقتناع شبه اقتناع كلي
ان التدخلات الاجنبيه يجب ان تتوقف في
المنطقه العربيه نحن نمر الان بمرحله
تجاذبات الولايات المتحده روسيا الصين كل
هذه الدول بدات في تسابق محموم لكسب منطقه
الشرق الاوسط فهذا فرصه يعني وافره للدول
العربيه ان تستقل بقراراتها بعيدا عن
التاثيرات الدوليه نعم اهم ما في ورد في
هذه في في البيان الختامي
التشديد على القضيه الفلسطينيه
والتعاون العربي العربي ونبذ الخلافات هذا
يعني يفتح للعالم العربي صفحه جديده في
تاريخنا المعاصر في سبيل الانعتاق من
الماضي والخلافات البينيه التي يعني رافقت
قيام الدول العربيه الحديثه منذ
حتى هذه الليله
برايك انت ما اهم ما طرح في هذه القمه
اما طرح هو تثبيت الدور السعودي بانها
اللاعب الرئيسي الان المحوري في المنطقه
التي تلعب دور اساسي هذه خامس قمه عربيه
تستضيف السعوديه وتسعى يعني الكلمات التي
استمعنا اليها من القاده كانت يعني
متفائله جدا تدعو الى التعاون تدعو الى رص
الصفوف الى تكثيف الجهود ولكن في نهايه
الامر الملفات لا تزال عالقه يعني احنا
قاعد اتكلم عن الازمه 75 سنه عمر الصراع
العربي الاسرائيلي مثل 48 والنكبه 75 سنه
على عمر الجامعه الدول العربيه 32 قمه
عاديه ولكن في نهايه الامر المواطن العربي
لا يشعر بان هناك بالفعل في انجازات
المفاجاه الكبيره كان عوده الاسد تحفظ
الوحيد العربي كان من قطر وهذا موقف مبدئي
من قطر على
مده طويله وكذلك مفاجاه على المستوى
الدولي كانت حضور زيلنسكي الرئيس
الاوكراني الذي بلاده تتعرض لحرب وغزو
وعدوان روسي منذ 15 شهر ولكن يعني في
المحصله النهائيه هناك كثير من التفاؤل
ولكن الواقع يقول بان القمم العربيه تنتهي
بنهايه الامر بتكرار المشهد يعني انا كتبت
مقال في القدس العربي بعد القمه الاخيره
في نوفمبر في
الجزائر
سميتها يعني مياه قديمه في قوارير جديده
يعني نعمل ان قمه التي برز فيها خلاف على
ما يبدو حول سوريا يثير الكثير من النقاش
والكثير من علامات الاستفهام حول اعاده
النظام السوري دون ان يكون في اي التزامات
يعني كيف يعاد النظام السوري دون ان يقدم
التزامات حول القضايا الاساسيه يعني
مستقبل العلاقه مع المعارضه الاستجابه
لقرار 2254
ايضا مخرجات جينيف واحد كيف يعود اللاجئين
واين الى اين يعودون
الكبتاجون والمخدرات يعني لم نسمع اي
التزامات من النظام السوري واعلام يعني
الاعلام الموالي لسوريا للمحور المقاومه
يفسر او يمثل هذا بانه انتصار كبير وعوده
الى البيت العربي وارحب به جميع المتكلمين
وتحدثين اليوم ولكن
كيف يتم التعامل مع هذه القضايا نؤكد على
نقطتين ايضا واختم بذلك النقطه الاولى
هناك تحول مهم في النظام الاقليمي الشرق
الاوسط
باستثناء التصعيد الاسرائيلي نرى ايضا
ثمار التقارب السعودي
الايراني عبر الوساطه الصينيه
ونرى ايضا يعني محاوله لخفض التصعيد
والتركيز على الاقتصاد والاستثمار والرؤى
الخليجيه على راسها السعوديه عشرين ثلاثين
وقطر والكويت وعمان وغيرهم يعني نحن ننتقل
الان عن مرحله المواجهه الى مرحله التهدئه
في هذه القمه ولكن ايضا النقطه الاخيره
اين امريكا من كل ذلك يعني امريكا هي
الحاضر الغائب التي لم يكن لها اي دور او
اي حضور او اي نقاش يعني الحضاره الروس
وحضروا الصينيين وحضر حتى الاوكرانيين
ولكن الدوري الامريكي لا يبدو انه في في
هذا المشهد خاصه وانه يصر على عدم رفع
العقوبات على نظام السوري وايضا النقطه
المهمه لن يسمح لاي طرف بان يعيد اعمار
سوريا بسبب عقوبات امريكا المفروضه بقانون
قيصر بفرض عقوبات على اي شركه او اي جهه
تقوم بالاستثمار او اعاده البناء في سوريا
فنحن لم نقطع الطريق بعد لازال هناك
الكثير من العراقيل والعقبات امام
الاندماج الكلي وماذا يعني ذلك يعني ولكن
هناك مسحه من التفاؤل استطيع ان اقول
نتيجه لما شهدناه اليوم خلال القمه التي
لم تطول اكثر من ثلاث ساعات
تعود اليك دكتور شجره لكن دكتور سعد هل
القاده العرب بعد هذه القمه قادرون على
ايجاد حلول لملفات كثيره جزيئه على ذكرها
خاصه تلك التي تشهد خلافات بينهم نعم هناك
توجه عام في المنطقه العربيه الى
جعل الخلافات وراء الظهر يعني لاحظنا انا
وزير الخارجيه في المؤتمر وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه انه قال عن الضمانات السوريه
ومساله المصالحه ان هناك خطوه بخطوه معنى
ذلك ان سوريا كل ما قدم اقدمت على خطوه
يقابلها بالتالي الخطوه الاخرى اللي هي
يعني اعمار مساعدات اقتصاديه بالنسبه
للعقوبات الامريكيه هناك عقوبات امريكيه
متواجده منذ القدم على سوريا قبل الحرب
هذه وهناك عقوبات امريكيه كانت على ليبيا
وعلى السودان لا يمنع التعاون البيني بين
الدول العربيه يعني لا تخيفنا امريكا الى
هذه الدرجه
السعوديه
والمؤتمر الذي عقد في عمان يعني اخذ
التزامات من الاخوه في سوريا انهم
يتعاونون تعاونا كليا مع مبادره الجامعه
العربيه ومبادره المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في
شمل سوريا في ضمن العضو الجامعه العربيه
والسوريون الان الحكومه السوريه تعي هذا
الدور الذي تطرح المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بخطوه بخطوه كلما تقدمت خطوه كلما حصلت
على ما تريد طبعا هذا الشيء ضروري ان نبقى
حبيسين
الخلافات السابقه ما هي الضمانات ما هي
لماذا كذا لماذا كذا يجب ان ننعتق من
السياسه نحن الان في سياسه وفي عهد جديد
في المجتمع العربي باكمله الدول العربيه
انت لاحظت الكلمات كل الدول العربيه
تقريبا بما فيها سوريا يعني كانت كلمه
السيد بشار الاسد كلمه تصالحيه بمعنى
الكلمه يستوعب الدوره التي يقوم بسوريا
الان نحن في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي
جمله جميع الدول العربيه نحتاج سوريا يعني
لا نحاول ان نخبي هذا الدور سوريا لها دور
مركزي في الامه العربيه يجب ان تعود اما
بالنسبه للضمانات السوريه فهي مثل ما تفضل
وزير الخارجيه خطوه بخطوه هناك مشاكل داخل
الدول العربيه في ليبيا في السودان في
اليمن كل هذه المشاكل ادعى الوفود ان تحل
داخل نطاق المجموعات العربيه وعلى ذلك شكل
لجان في لمراجعه هذه الملفات والمساعده في
حلولها طبعا
التدخل الخارجي هو المشكله في العالم
العربي اذا ما انتفى التدخل الخارجي وحل
محل الدور العربي والبيني انحلت كثير من
تلك المشاكل الان العالم العربي هو
المتسيد
باقتصادياته
بامتلاكها الطاقه فاعتقد ان الدول العظمى
التي تحاول ان تخرب مثلا مثل ما تفضل
السيد عبد الله قال الدور الامريكي ما هو
موجود
الدول العظمى تحاول ان تتقرب للمنطقه
العربيه بما لها من اقتصاديات هائله وطاقه
تحتاجها الدول يعني اوروبا الان في نقص
كبير للطاقه سواء الطاقه الغاز او البترول
كل هذا الامر انتهى يعني من هذه الليله
سيكون هناك شرق اوسط جديد بمعنى الكلمه
يعني ان شاء الله انه يكون على ما نتخيل
وما نتمنى وما ذكر في القمه من كلمات يعني
اعتقد انه للروس ولا الامريكان يستطيعون
ان يقفون
امام الاراده العربيه في التصالح في
التعاون الاقتصادي وزير الخارجيه السعودي
ركز على موضوع اهم المملكه اهم الوطن
العربي باكمله اللي هو الاستدامه في
التنميه
نعم سوف ناتي على ذكر الاستدامه في
التنميه والملفات الاخرى ولكن حتى نختم
هذه الجزئيه فيما يخص الملف السوري دكتور
الشايجي على ذكرى التدخل الخارجي والقمه
ركزت عليه بالنسبه لسوريا كيف يمكن
التعامل مع موضوع تعقيدات
الوجود الاجنبي العسكري داخل سوريا بحيث
يخفف وطئه ما يحدث على المشهد السوري وعلى
الشعب السوري
يعني هذه هي المشكله الكبيره يعني خطوه
مقابل خطوه يعني المفروض النظام يبدا
بالخطوه وليس العرب يعني هو الذي تم تعليق
عضويته بسبب عسكره الثوره فمفروض النظام
هو الذي يبادر انا لم ارى اي خطوه يعني
بعد يعني الهدف هو على ما يبدو عند النظام
العربي هو ان استماله سوريا الى الحضن
العربي وهذا طبعا يعني مطلوب منذ زمن ولكن
هل سيكون ذلك على حساب العلاقه
الاستراتيجيه مع ايران نذكر يعني الرئيس
الايراني قبل اسابيع دمشق وكان لقاء حافل
وزاره ايضا قياديين في النظام الايراني
زاروا ايضا سوريا يعني يبدو بان العلاقه
استراتيجيه ومحوريه فكيف يمكن ان
ينتزع النظام السوري الى الحضن العربي كيف
يمكن ان تبقى الميليشيات التي احضرتها
ايران زينبيون وفاطميون كيف يمكن ان
يتعامل مع اعاده المهجرين واللاجئين اللي
هو نصف الشعب السوري تقريبا الى منازل مو
موجوده او مدن تم تم يعني تدميرها كيف
يمكن ان اخذ تعهدات حول مسار التصدير
الكبتاجون والمخدرات وغيرها يعني هذه هي
دلالات ايضا العلاقه مع المعارضه العلاقه
مع
2254 حكومه انتقاليه دستور جديد انتخابات
يعني هذا كله مو واضح يعني الخريطه الطريق
لاعاده سوريا الى الصف العربي التي معظم
الدول العربيه الان تؤيدها ولكن لا نرى
خريطه الطريق لتحقيق ذلك او جدول زمني
وماذا اذا لم يلتزم النظام ما هي الخطوه
اللي بعدها يعني نعيد قطع العلاقات نعيد
سحب السفراء بعدين الموقف هو ان كل دوله
الان يعني لا يعني ان عوده سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه ان سيكون تطبيع عربي يعني
هذا قرار سيادي لا يمكن لكل دوله ان تنصاع
لقرار الجامعه الدول العربيه بل كل دوله
لديه قرار السياده باعاده فتح سفارتها او
السماح لسوريا بان تفتح نظام الاسد ان
يفتح سفارته في تلك الدول فلا تزال الامور
عالقه علينا ان لا نحتفل مبكرا
نظام السوري الان تحت التجربه سنرى ماذا
سيقوم به ولهذا السبب يعني انا اتفهم
لماذا الرغبه موجوده ولكن هذه تصطدم بكثير
من العراقيل التي يجب ان تذلل قبل ان نؤكد
على ان سوريا عادت الى الصف العام وشفنا
كلمه الاسد يعني كانت في الكثير من
التفاخر حول المستقبل
وتزامنت هذه القمه مع اقتحام باحات الساحه
المسجد الاقصى والانتهاكات الاسرائيليه
والاستفزازات المستمره ماذا لدى القاده
العرب ليقدموه لهذه القضيه وللشعب
الفلسطيني ليس فقط بعبارات انشائيه ولكن
عمليه بحيث تختلف هذه القمه عن قمم
السابقه القضيه الفلسطينيه اولا هي قضيه
كل العرب وليست الفلسطين وحدهم وان نعرف
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي ما زالت
الدوله الاقوى والاكبر والاكثر نفاذا في
المجتمع الدولي بالنسبه للقضيه الفلسطينيه
هناك اكثر من وسيله لرفع معاناه المعاناه
عن الشعب الفلسطيني هناك مشاريع امريكيه
مطلوبه في الشرق الاوسط سواء مشاريع
سياسيه او مشاريع اقتصاديه
والتعاون الولايات المتحده كوسيط بين
العرب واسرائيل
احيانا يكون مشروب بتقدمها على الملف
الفلسطيني طبعا
اي دوله اخرى مثل روسيا او الصين تاثيرها
يكاد يكون معدوم على الكيان الاسرائيلي
لكن الاداره الامريكيه حصولها على مشاريع
كبرى في المنطقه
والمملكه لديها مشاريع كبرى ايضا وبقيه
الدول كل هذا الامر اذا يعني وجدت هناك
علاقه بين التقدم على الفلسطيني وهذا وهذه
المشاريع كان هناك يعني يعني شيء ملموس في
في اليد على الارض طبعا الفلسطينيين الان
يحاولون او المملكه تحاول ان يكون القرار
فلسطيني بحث القرار الفلسطيني ليس لديه ما
يملكه من تاثير على الولايات المتحده وعلى
الدول الخارجيه لكن المملكه والدول
المؤثره في المنطقه سواء اقتصاديا او
سياسيا لديها القدره طبعا الولايات
المتحده يعني حاولت في اكثر من مره ولعلكم
تذكرون صفقه القرن كيف ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بالدرجه الاولى هي التي
اوقفتها لماذا يعني هناك مقيدات اقتصاديه
واستراتيجيه بين المملكه وامريكا العلاقات
السعوديه الاسرائيليه التي تحاول اسرائيل
ان تجعلها السعوديه رفضت هذه هذا كرت كبير
جدا للاسرائيليين
طيب انا اريد ان اسال الدكتور الشايجي مع
كل ما شهدته هذه القمه هل نحن امام بالفعل
صفحه جديده يكون فيها تصفير للمشاكل وعلى
هذا الاساس يتم حل المشاكل بتعقيداتها
المعروفه في المنطقه
يعني بس لو سمحت بالنسبه لقضيه الفلسطينيه
انا يعني كنت اتمنى لو القمه العربيه
اتخذت قرار بتطبيق يعني المبادره العربيه
لقمه بيروت ب 2002 التي كانت يعني مبادره
للراحل الملك عبد الله عندما كان ولي
العهد في قمه بيروت لاول مره اتفقوا العرب
على ان تكون هناك مبادره عربيه تجاه
الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي والقضيه
الفلسطينيه الانسحاب الاسرائيلي الكامل من
كامل المحتله بما فيها القدس الشرقيه
والضفه الغربيه والجولان السوري المحتال
وجمازارع شمعه في جنوب لبنان مقابل تطبيع
جميع العرب الذي حدث هو بالالعام 2020 ان
4 دول عربيه طبعت مع اسرائيل مخالفه بذلك
قرار القمه العربيه والمبادره العربيه
فالقمه العربيه اكدت اليوم بانه التمسك
بالمبادره العربي كيف نتمسك بالمؤادره
العربيه وفي دول خرقتها وخلفتها وما هي
الرساله لاسرائيل التي تطبع والتي يعني
تعيث فسادا بفلسطين وتشن كل صيف حرب على
غزه وتقمع الفلسطينيين ما عندنا اراضي
لاسرائيل الا موقف عربي يتمسك بالقمه
العربيه ويوقف ويفرمل التطبيع ويتخذ
اجراءات بالفعل تؤلم اسرائيل توقف التعاون
المالي والتجاري والتبادل وغيره ويعني لان
عندك انت اكثر حكومه متطرفه بتاريخ فيها
فاشيين وفيها يعني وزراء يسكنون في
مستوطنات ولا يعترفون بحق الفلسطيني وشفنا
امس مسيره الاعلام اما بالنسبه الى تصفير
المشاكل نامل بذلك يعني هناك بالفعل في
هذه القمه لاول مره احس ان هناك في اجواء
من التفاؤل اجواء من الارتياح حتى ما كان
في داعي لجلسه سريه لدينا تقريبا دقيقه
باختصار على موضوع تصفير المشاكل كمرحله
جديده دكتور عبد الله
يعني هناك اجواء تفاؤل عثمان مثل ما قلت
ولكن يعني هذا بحاجه الى اثبات اكثر بحاجه
الى تصفير المشاكل حول القضايا الخلافيه
منها التطبيع ومنها عوده النظام السوري
ومنها قضايا اخرى عالقه بين الدول يعني
الملفت كان غياب رؤساء دول مؤثرين ومهمين
عن هذه القمه ما هي الرساله التي ترسل
يعني لهذا السبب يعني هناك اجواء تفاؤل
ولكن التجربه هي ستكون كيف سنتحرك من من
هذه من هذه من اليوم من ختام هذه القمه
الى القمه القادمه كما كيف ستحل مشكله
السودان مثلا ليبيا هل سنصل الى اتفاق
وهدنه في اليمن نهائيه بين الحوثيين وبين
السعوديه
مجلس التعاون الخليجي يعود الى لعب دوره
الرئيسي شكرا شكرا جزيلا يعني وضعها صعب
جدا ولهذا السبب هناك امل بان التفاعل
ولكن يجب ان يكون حجري
استاذ العلوم سياسيه حدثنا من بيروت
واشكر كذلك الدكتور سعد بن عمرو رئيس مركز
القرن العربي للدراسات بشكل خاص طبعا طوال
وجودك معنا في التغطيه هذه للقمه العربيه
مشاهدينا الكرام بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر التي قدمناها لكم
من جده في المملكه العربيه السعوديه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]